[Applause]
we might have michael for
i don't know three four hours timeless i
don't know if he knows that yet that's
uh
called strike rail muto goes down three
straight k's for
responsibility is not just on the field
it's also in that clubhouse
and in the lineup too a line drive base
hit for cervelli
a one out knock and that's the first hit
of the ball game for either side
and he wants the ball
to the right side kingry it glances off
his glove cervelli's on his way to third
and he'll get there that'll be
back-to-back hits
that puts riders on first and third with
one out here in the third
the green light roman quinn out in
center field
tagging a third of cervelli quinn's
throw goes to second
at a rental score the marlins take a
one-nothing lead to sac fly for vr
two outs here in the third marlins lead
at one-nothing
about a sac fly from jonathan vr that
came in the third we go to the top of
the fourth inning
better goes swinging to miss throw to
second base
is in time a strikeout throw out double
play
oh caught stealing by maybe the best in
the game
at least for the moment jt real muto don
mattingly with the hand up they
might take a look at it seemed to be a a
close play
bench coach james rousen on the phone
with the video room to see whether or
not they're going to challenge that call
or not
well at first glance i was actually
surprised at the alcohol but
against the marlins right-hander that
ball is blasted deep to right field it
is gone first home run of the year for
the fills
comes from the newest fill d.d gregorius
it's a one-one game this guy here
he has a chance to be a difference maker
in this lineup
guy that can hit the middle of the
lineup hit for power i mean he really
when he got to the yankees and he
realized you know i could pull the ball
on that short porch
it he he became a dangerous dangerous
player
submitting miguel rojas leads it off 102
coming from nola
and that is drilled left center field
and gone a home run for jesus aguilar
his first as a marlin and it breaks the
tie oh
[Music]
do breaking ball right down the middle
of the plate a little bit down
the big man all over almost like he knew
it was coming
see a little hesitation in his swing and
then he just unloads
welcome big boy to the marlins that
honor nation scouting report
dickerson down the right field line this
one's going to rattle around the corner
harper digs it out and dickerson puts on
the brakes
the ball funneled all the way to third
base but uh one out double for corey
dickerson
over power hitter that's 96 miles an
hour at the top of the zone
and that one gets away from him and
dickerson's gonna score
up to third ramirez and the marlins get
another in what is now a three-run
inning
85-80 you know pitch levitt that
he'd still been in there off the end of
the back carries well though vr
drop the baseball rounding third and
heading for home is dede gregorius he'll
score
it's a 5-2 game maybe that's the break
the phillies need
dd kept going a lot of guys would shut
it down if dd kept running
never don't take anything for granted
right past reese hoskins and into right
field so
two hits in his marlins debut dickerson
on with one away in the eighth
[Applause]
and his line into left field a base hit
dickerson holds up at second base and
the marlins have two on and two out so
for andy get that first hit of the year
take a deep breath that's good
that one's floating over the head of
aguilar for a base hit for reese
he'll take that
seeing a beauty thing of beauty
we go to the top of the ninth inning
didn't just take it but uh
took it and ran with it ran with it and
gets another base hit right there
so miggy's aboard marlins have two more
runners on base right now one out in the
ninth inning
rounds one to hoskins who will step on
the bag the other runners move up with
two outs
we got three on the right side against
bruce brown ball
diaz rojas and over to first
that's a double play feels so good to
say this again
it's a marlins win 5-2 an opening day
victory for the miami marlins how do you
like that